[Music]
my childhood traumas are not like yours
[Music]
you see
i'm accursed playing more
hey guys pete here i wanted to do a
quick ozark season 4 part 2 video today
because they did put out a short teaser
as a date announcement there isn't much
here but i did like how they refocused
things back on ruth you have this
mystery of the birds car accident that's
hanging over the final episodes the
flash forward they opened the season
with that kind of takes over a lot of
the conversation about what's going to
happen and this is here to remind you
that ruth is going to be out for revenge
after what happened to wyatt
in my last video i said i thought the
release date would likely be at the end
of april and that turned out to be true
i thought it made the most sense and
yesterday we found out that ozark season
4 part 2 will drop on april 29th 2022
the remaining seven episodes of the
series will be available and we'll learn
how this story ends the teaser is a mix
of scenes some are from the first part
that we've already seen with some brand
new ones mixed in it has a voiceover
from ruth which i think is just recycled
from season two but i suppose it's
possible she's reading this again and if
you're wondering where it came from this
is the letter wyatt wrote when he was
trying to get into college in the third
episode of the second season ruth came
in and read it to him because she was
worried he wasn't taking it seriously
and also because it's dark if not plain
sad or depressing i thought this was a
smart callback because there was a lot
of distance between these two characters
in season three and this relationship is
so important in defining who ruth is it
underlines all that she's lost since she
decided to steal the bird's money back
in season one and how the association
with marty and his family got us to
where we are heading into the ending of
the story in voice over we hear her read
his words my childhood traumas are not
like yours you see i'm a cursed
langmower long in order to violence and
death and in the case of a langmore
perhaps not soon enough there are two
lines that are omitted from this
original letter but the spirit is the
same as far as what we see in the teaser
most of the early shots are from part
one we see wyatt at the trailer and ruth
driving away after discovering the
bodies there's a new one of crime tape
on darlene's front door and a shot of
navarro in his jail cell with his door
opening nothing jumps out here he looks
like he's in the same jumpsuit that he
was wearing in the finale and you can
see that his hand still has the bandage
on it so not much time has probably
passed there's a quick shot of hobby
smiling which i think is new although
it's hard to say what's going on he
might be talking to claire shaw here
then there's one of the more interesting
shots this is the new character camila
alexandro omar navarro's sister hobby's
mother she's supposed to play a large
role in part two and in this shot we see
marty meeting with her in mexico another
interesting one has ruth turning on the
light in darlene's barn and there's a
lot of dope packaged up and ready to go
it's been a question as to what will
happen to her property and her poppy
farm and i don't know if ruth would end
up getting control of those what i
hadn't considered though was that there
may be a large amount of processed
heroin ready to go in that case what we
see here someone would have to get rid
of all of that and this would equate to
a pretty substantial windfall of cash
for ruth this makes sense because who
else would be able to make this
disappear that might give her something
to work with when she sets out to go
after hobby in the closing shot ruth is
looking at a handgun on the seat of her
truck and on the screen it says the end
arrives sooner than you think so it's an
interesting tease but it is just that a
tease it's not a lot to go off of like i
said in my last video i am interested to
see how she goes after hobby what that
looks like i think the two new
characters are the wild cards chuck who
we met briefly in part one and hobby's
mother camila it was nice to see a shot
of her and i'd be interested to see how
you think these two characters will
factor into her plans and i think that's
about all there is to say here so i'll
leave it there let me know in the
comments what you thought about the
teaser the release date and how you're
hoping the series will end please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon